john bainer he's the Speaker of the
House he's a very very tan man and guess
what he is suing President Obama that's
right he has had it with these executive
actions that basically the Republicans
have forced President Obama to take
because they won't allow him to get any
legislation to his desk to sign and now
they're saying he's overreaching so
Boehner is actually forming a lawsuit to
sue the president over this and the
President Obama's not too happy about it
and we've got some video you know that
the suit is a stunt but what I've told
Speaker Boehner directly is if you're
really concerned about me taking too
many executive actions why don't you try
getting something done through Congress
the majority of American people want to
see immigration reform done we had a
bipartisan bill through the Senate and
you're gonna squawk if I try to fix some
parts of it administratively that are
within my authority while you are not
doing it okay so just to be very clear
what's happening here the Republicans
are not giving him any legislation to
sign so he's trying to take power with
which is within his right even though
I've talked a lot about how I'm not for
the executive actions and I believe in
separation of powers and all that but
they're pretty much giving him no choice
he seems pretty pissed therefore Obama
that's actually pretty pissed don't you
think I agree well he's right that it's
a stunt and it's got nothing to do with
him it's all about the fact that John
Boehner knows how deeply the tea party
hates him and this is nothing more than
a craven plea to the tea party to
respect him by doing something
disgusting Obama has had significantly
fewer executive orders of the President
Bush which never bothered anyone
yeah and it's literally like 20% well
yeah yeah you know this is but this is
Agent Orange is whole thing he's got
nothing going he has no legislative
agenda no legislative agenda whatsoever
and this is why when they want to talk
about Obama having a low approval rating
well Congress has a lower approval
rating than chlamydia chlamydia is like
at 5:15 fun getting there as opposed to
John Boehner so this is all look when
they were voting last year on who the
Speaker of the House should be they were
several rather conspicuous protest votes
against Speaker Boehner Louie Gohmert
actually voted
or for what's-his-face the lunatic Ted
Cruz no not Ted Cruz the the Alan West
rich lunatic there's so many Allen
West's so it's his Thorazine flushed
itself down the toilet
well he's out of a job out of a job then
yeah Gohmert voted for a guy who had
been voted out of Congress to be the
Speaker of the House over Speaker
Boehner he knows how deeply unpopular he
is that his biggest ally was Eric Cantor
who wanted his job this is John Boehner
desperation showing through and it's not
gonna make the Tea Party like him
anymore and that really didn't work out
for Eric Cantor so before we get into
too much of the political minutiae of
this did you know that they could even
sue the president doesn't it seem like
the worst possible like our governments
so dysfunctional and by the way you can
sue the president well here's one I'm
seeing I'm seeing Boehner being
desperate I'm seeing Obama being angry
and I feel like the best way to solve
this is with reality television show
when I would absolutely support a stunt
like that if I could watch it play out
on TV yeah is what do we do about this
because this is something we talk about
every week on this that just the
branches of government no longer work
that Obama's being forced and they
weren't if you work it not to sound like
a man in a room but they work if you
work at it right but what with the
construct that we have now just with it
with the Republicans sort of being held
hostage by the Tea Party like it's just
nothing's working
so what do we do to make this work
instead of going to Idi otic lawsuits
and forcing the president's hand to do
things that a lot of people don't want
him to do in that kind of thing well I
mean this is Obama's making it work
that's why he's doing this the American
people don't want to sit around and you
know complain about the government they
want the government to do stuff for them
but it is in the interest of the GOP to
make government as weak as possible they
serve the CEOs the struggle in our
country has never been the conservative
versus liberal it's aristocracy versus
democracy and it is in the interest of
the upper 1% of the upper point oh one
percents evil half to keep government
from working and I find it interesting
the same people who are trying to weaken
government here are complaining that
other countries of you our government is
a weak
I love that line I saw you tweeted it
earlier it's
you know exactly what they do they want
their getting exactly what they want
they want the gridlock they want nothing
to happen because if government works
that means democracy works and if
democracy works that means the people
are gonna run this country and that is
not in the interest of these in vassals
of the Koch brothers
so going to your reality show point
should we have more cameras around
what's going on really is do you
remember during the Obamacare debate
even President Obama said we will have
this all open to everybody and will air
at all and c-span of course none of that
happen I don't and I think the Democrats
don't want it just as much as the
Republicans don't want so really
shouldn't we have not that has to be a
reality show we're voting people off
although I think that's a pretty good
idea but should we have just more
cameras around so some of this stuff is
actually true or at least a really well
made a Netflix documentary I mean that
changed everyone's mind on Romney if
that had come out before the election
things would have gone very different
was about an old baseball glove and that
would have been more interesting now for
you you're right though I know I think
the Supreme Court should be on
television I think student I think
classrooms I think public school
classrooms should be on the Internet
I think executions should be televised
we're paying for it I will if you
televised executions you'd see the
numbers on death penalty flip overnight
so you think it would go do I think is
so sadistic it might actually go people
who go to church and call themselves
Christians despite the fact that Jesus
quite clearly spoke out against killing
the sinner he never mentioned birth
control never mentioned abortion never
mentioned gay people did speak out about
killing the center rather specifically
if these people saw the murder that
their tax dollars pay for and by the way
I like that they don't consider it
murder if the state does it it doesn't
get more big government that's trapping
a guy to a table and poisoning him to
death right and doing it in front of
viewers yes although sometimes the guy
that's actually doing the poisoning or
the electrocution or whatever there
doesn't even know because they have them
blind all taxpayers have a right to see
as much of what they pay for as possible
that doesn't jeopardize national
security yeah all right televised case
extra so they know what they're missing
out on that's the next step in the gay
rights movement is televise gay sex
sorry God you guys are looking at the
wrong porn sites you don't know